G라고 이름 붙인 Grover 연산 자체인데요. N개의 qubit에 모두 적용되는 연산들의 조합이에요. 그러니까 이건 N
qubit 연산이에요. 먼저 ZF gate가 있어요. 다시 말해 입력
함수 f에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate이고, 그다음 Hadamard gate 레이어, 그리고 or 함수에 대한 위상 쿼리 gate인 zor이 있어요.
마지막으로 또 다른 Hadamard gate 레이어가 있어요. 그래서 2단계에서 한 번의 반복은
여기 화면에 표시된 형태의 circuit으로 구현할 수 있어요. 참고로 여기서는 4개의 qubit이 있는데,
일반적으로는 임의의 수의 qubit이 있을 수 있어요. 여기서 주목할 핵심 사항은 G를 구현하는 데 f에 대한 쿼리가 하나 필요하다는 거예요.
ZF를 구현하는 데 쿼리 하나가 필요하고, 다른 연산들은 F에 의존하지 않으므로 쿼리가 필요 없어요. 그래서 2단계에서 G를
적용하는 횟수를 나타내는 숫자 T가 필요한 쿼리 횟수도 나타내요.
여기 Grover의 알고리즘을 사용하는 일반적인 방법이 있는데, 물론 유일한 방법은 아니에요. 앞서 말했듯이
먼저 해야 할 건 T를 선택하는 거예요. 다음 섹션에서 그걸 다룰게요.
선택한 T에 대해 T번 반복으로 Grover의 알고리즘을 실행하면 후보 해
X를 얻어요. X가 정말 해라는 보장은 없지만, 추가로 쿼리 한 번으로 확인할 수 있어요. 해가 있으면
그 해를 출력하고 멈춰요. 그렇지 않으면 다시 시도할 수 있어요. 아마 다른 T 값으로요.
꼭 그럴 필요는 없지만요. 또는 포기하고 해가 없다고 보고할 수도 있어요. 앞서 말했듯이,
이게 알고리즘을 사용하는 유일한 방법은 아니지만, 탐색 문제에 적용하는 자연스러운 방법이에요. 다음으로 Grover
연산이 작용하는 N개의 qubit 상태에 실제로 무슨 일을 하는지 볼게요. n개의 qubit을
이름을 붙이자면 Q라고 부를 단일 레지스터로 생각해 봐요. Grover의 알고리즘에서 처음에 하는 건
Q를 모든 n비트 문자열의 균등 중첩 상태로 만드는 거예요. 그걸 Hadamard
gate를 all-zero 상태의 n개의 qubit에 적용해서 해요. 그다음 Grover 연산 G를 반복하고
측정해요. 모든 n비트 문자열의 집합을 두 집합으로 분할하는 게 도움이 될 거예요. A0과
A1이요. A0에는 F가 0으로 평가되게 하는 모든 문자열이 들어 있고, A1에는 F가
1로 평가되게 하는 모든 문자열이 들어 있어요. 달리 말하면 A1에는 탐색
문제의 모든 해가 들어 있고, A0에는 모든 비해가 들어 있어요. 특히
두 가지 양자 상태에 관심이 있어요. 하나는 모든 비해에 대한 균등 중첩인 ket A0이고,
다른 하나는 모든 해에 대한 균등 중첩인 ket A1이에요. 이 정의들은
이 집합들이 비어 있지 않을 때만 의미가 있다는 걸 지적해야 해요. 그렇지 않으면 0개를 합산하고 0으로 나누는 게 되니까요.
Grover의 알고리즘 분석을 진행하면서 그 가정을 할 거예요. f가 상수 0 함수이거나 상수 1 함수일 때
Grover의 알고리즘이 무엇을 하는지 특수한 경우로 처리해서 매우 쉽게 파악할 수 있어요. 하지만 그건
직접 해 보도록 남겨 둘게요. 당연히 모든 문자열이 해라면 측정할 때 실제로
해를 얻을 거고, 해가 없다면 하나도 얻지 못할 거예요. 그 경우에는 아무것도 없으니까요.
하지만 이 분석을 위해 이 두 집합이 모두 비어 있지 않다고 가정할 거예요. 그래야
이 두 상태의 정의가 의미 있으니까요. 참고로, 이건 꽤 일반적인
표기법이에요. 비어 있지 않은 유한 집합 s가 있을 때마다 ket s를 그
집합의 원소들에 대한 균등 중첩을 의미하는 것으로 쓸 수 있어요. 여기처럼요. 이 정의들을 이렇게 정리해 봐요. Grover의
알고리즘과 어떻게 연결되는지 볼 거예요. Grover의 알고리즘의 첫 번째 단계는 초기화 단계로, Q를 모든 n비트 문자열에 대한 균등
중첩 상태로 만들어요. 이 상태에 쉽게 알아볼 수 있는 이름을 붙이기 위해
ket u라고 부를게요. u는 균등(uniform)의 약자예요. 분석을 위해 먼저 주목해야 할 중요한 사항은
이 균등 상태 ket u가 ket a0과 ket
A1 두 벡터가 생성하는 부분공간에 포함된다는 거예요. 특히 화면에 표시된 이 두 상태의 선형 조합을 취하면 ket
u를 얻을 거예요. 이제 전체 분석의 핵심은 Q의 상태가
Grover 연산을 몇 번 적용하든 이 2차원 부분공간 안에 머문다는 사실이에요. 그러니까 모든 것이
2차원 부분공간에서 무슨 일이 일어나는지로 귀결돼요. 이제 Grover 연산이 무엇을 하는지, 특히
ket a0과 ket
A1이 생성하는 2차원 부분공간의 벡터들에게 무엇을 하는지 살펴봐요. g가 두 부분으로 나뉜다고 상상하면 도움이 돼요. 한 부분은 ZF
gate이고, 다른 부분은 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 zor gate예요.
이전에 나온 ZF의 정의가 있는데, 그 정의에서 비해와 해의 균등 중첩인 두 상태에 대한 작용이
ket A1 앞에 마이너스 부호를 붙이는 것임을 알 수 있어요.
ket a0에는 아무 일도 일어나지 않고, 이 분석을 위해 ZF에 대해 알아야 할 건 그게 전부예요.
두 번째 부분인 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진
Z or gate에 대해서는, zor이 어떻게 정의되는지 떠올리는 것부터 시작해요. 쓰는 한 가지 방법은
화면에 표시된 것처럼이에요. 이건 이전과 같은 표현이고, 직접 표기법으로 표현하는 또 다른 방법은 이렇게예요.
우변의 연산이 표준 기저 상태에 어떻게 작용하는지 생각해보면 이 표현을 검증할 수 있어요.
특히 all-zero 상태에는 아무것도 하지 않고 다른 모든
표준 기저 상태는 마이너스 부호를 얻어요. Z or의 정의와 일치하죠.
그러니까 이 연산을 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼우면 비슷한 표현을 얻되,
all-zero 표준 기저 상태 대신 이제 균등 중첩 ket u가 있어요. H⊗n이
all-zero 표준 기저 상태를 ket u로 변환하고, H⊗n은 자신의 켤레 전치와 같으므로 비슷한 방식으로
bra에서 오른쪽으로부터 작용하기 때문이에요. 이제 지금까지 관찰한 사실들을 사용해서
G가 두 벡터 a0과 A1에 무엇을 하는지 파악할 거예요.
a0부터 시작해요. 먼저 두 레이어의 Hadamard gate 사이에 끼워진 Z or gate에 대해 얻은 표현을 대입해요.
그다음 ZF가 ket a0에 아무것도 하지 않는다는 사실을 사용할 수 있어요.